-Welcome back
to "Late Night."
We're here with Don Johnson.
Kenan Thompson is both
one of the warmest people
you could ever hope
to work with,
but I also always found it
frustrating, as well.
The guy never misses.
Every take,
he is just pitch perfect.
And you watch, this year,
what he's doing at "SNL" -
He's filming with you all week
He's coming back to "SNL"
without rehearsal,
nailing it there.
Are you as impressed
with Kenan as I am?
-Truly.
This is not
just actor goosh stuff.
This is -- Doing a show
like this is not --
[ Sighs ] Let's just face it
It's not what you would
immediately expect
Don Johnson to be doing.
And it was a little bit
of a risk, you know --
me coming in and taking on
this kind of a part and stuff.
And, frankly,
Kenan is such a pro
that he just --
He basically just catches me
and says, "Oh, no, you good.
You know, props me back up
and says, "Keep it going."
And I think
I've actually developed
a kind of a thing here,
you know?
And it's joyful, joyful, joyful,
to come into work every da
and laugh -- and we laugh.
And somehow,
I got Kenan's funny bone.
And Chris Redd too,
for some odd reason.
And maybe it's just becaus
I'm the crazy white guy.
-[ Laughs ]
-I don't know.
-It's nice to know
that it still has some currenc
to be a crazy white guy.
-Yeah, well, it's about the only
thing we really can own.
-[ Laughs ]
So, let me ask you this,
because you also had
incredible chemistry last year
For my money, the best show.
I guess now it's two years ago
Again, same thing as you.
Corona's mushed my brain.
But you and Regina King were s
good together in "Watchmen."
That must have been
an incredible thing
to be a part of.
-It really was.
You know, the funny thing
about "Watchmen"
is that Damon Lindelof --
who took the original
source material of "Watchmen
and then made this
masterpiece, basically --
He wrote me the most
gooshing, loving letter
that you could ever get.
And, of course, if you wan
an actor to do anything,
you just send him a letter
that's like this --
telling him he's basically
the greatest thing
since sliced bread --
and we'll do anything.
And by the way,
I think I gave him
one of his first jobs,
if not his first job.
He was on my writing staff
and he asked me if I'd com
and do him a favor.
And I said, "Yeah!"
You know, "Let me read it.
And I read it,
and he wouldn't tell me
anything more about it.
I had no idea
I was a white supremacist.
[ Laughter ]
I had no idea
that my grandfather was
a white supremacist.
That was a surprise
to all of us.
So, anyway, yeah.
I went down there,
and kind of simultaneously
I was shooting "Knives Out
with Daniel Craig
and that whole great cast
up there in Boston.
So I was back and forth
between Boston and Atlanta
It was a very
fertile time, Seth.
-[ Laughs ] That's nice.
It's nice that you had
your fertile time
right before all of us
had to stop doing anything
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-That's good.
It's good timing.
You talk about how sometimes
a little sweet-talking
is helpful for actors.
You were so great
in "Django Unchained" --
Quentin Tarantino movie.
And I heard tell
that he might have been
sort of a bigger fan
of your work
and more knowledgeable of it
than even you were.
-Oh, well,
he's more knowledgeable
of everyone's work.
-Right.
-Because Quentin is
a walking film historian.
And before I got the part,
we were at one of these joints
in L.A. somewhere
for an after party
of some sort.
And he walked up to me
and he said,
"Do you know what, I just --
You know what
I just loved you in?
I-I-I just loved you
in this movie that you did."
And I said,
"You know, that's great,
but I didn't do that movie."
He says, "Oh, yes,
you did that movie."
I said, "No, no.
I've never heard of the movie.
I don't know the movie."
But anyway, he said,
"Oh, no."
And he started to tell me
the story of the movie
and name the people
that were in the movie
and the DP and the director.
And I went...
[ Thumps hand ]
"Oh, yeah!
I was in that movie."
[ Laughter ]
-That's fantastic!
-It was absurd.
I mean, I forgot, you know
-Yeah, well, that just speak
to the breadth of your career.
You've got a couple in there
that you didn't even remember.
-[ Laughs ] There's a few
of them I haven't even seen.
-Your daughter Dakota is
obviously an accomplished acto
in her own right...
[ Stammers ]
-Who is that?
-[ Laughs ] Dakota.
We'll send you clips.
-Oh, yes!
-She's been on this show.
-Oh, the movie star Dakota
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And let me just say, such
a fantastic talk show guest.
We always love having her here
She is just unique
and wonderful.
But I wonder,
does she come to you
at this point in her caree
and ask for advice?
Or that is something
that happened decades ago?
-That bus left.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
That bus left.
She doesn't need any
advice from me.
I mean, she --
You know, the funny thing
about her is,
we have a rule in the family
that if you stay in school
you get to stay on the payroll
So, if you go to college,
And towards the end
of high school,
I went to her and I said,
"Um, so, do you want to go
visit some colleges
or something like that?"
And she went, "Oh, no,
I'm not going to college."
And I went, "Okay.
Well, you know what that means
I mean, you won't be
on the payroll anymore,
and how are you gonna manage?"
And she says,
"Don't you worry about it.
-[ Laughing ]
-And I said, "Eh, okay.
Well, what do you got in mind?
She said, "Just --"
[ Stammers, scoffs ]
Three weeks later,
she had nailed down that par
in David Fincher's
"The Social Network,"
and the rest is,
shall we say, cinema history
So, no, she doesn't really
call me for advice.
She calls me to say that,
"Uh, gosh, I would see you
but I've got three picture
that I'm shooting
at the same time."
-Well, I think
we all hope one day
our kids are successful enough
to not have time to call us.
-But she's gainfully employed,
and Seth, that's a great day
-That's all you can ask for.
I look forward
to that day myself.
Hey, Don, this has been an
absolute delight talking to you.
It's equally delightful seeing
you and Kenan do your thing.
Thanks so much for making time
for us today.
-Oh, man.
It was a joy for me to be here
Thank you so much.
-"Kenan" airs Tuesday nights
here on NBC.